this is a production of cornell
university
okay so i want to give you a little bit
of context
um
for the location of these trials so
delaware
is located there in the southern part of
the mid-atlantic region
and we have six to eight thousand acres
of snap beans planted in the state every
year
the end use of those is both for
processing and fresh market
and planting starts at the end of april
and continues
up until august
with harvest starting in july and up
until frost around october 20th
the soils in this area are primarily
sandy looms or lumi sands so quite light
and well drained most of the time
because our soils are so light all of
our production is irrigated
with
overhead
pivot irrigation in most cases
uh sometimes we do have problems with
water logging and root rots
we have pretty high water tables we also
have
not so much in the way of topography
so
we get low areas in fields that don't
drain
so we do have some root
disease issues
and
we do have annual problems with heat
stress especially in plantings that went
in in may and june
and then
are subject to high temperatures in june
and july when they are flowering
so i'm going to start out by talking uh
more about the physiology of heat stress
in snap beans
the temperatures that we're most
concerned about are the nighttime
temperatures
and the chart that's
on the slide that i'm showing you are
the
daily max and min temperatures
for july 2020 so this was in the
flowering period of one of our 2020
trials that was planted on june 9th
and
sort of the optimal nighttime
temperature
for snap beans is 65 degrees
and we start
seeing
quality and yield loss
at 68 degrees at night so you can see
that
many
daytime minimum temperatures
are
above that threshold of 68 degrees
fahrenheit
in this time period and
harvest for this trial began
on july 27th
and flowering was around july 13th
the most susceptible growth stage to
high temperatures for snap beans
is in the
10 days
prior to flower opening
and then during early flowering so that
is when the flowers and the flower buds
so the flowers that are forming can be
damaged by the high nighttime
temperatures
so
the this particular planting there were
a fair number of nights above the 68
degree threshold in
that time period when
the plants are going to be susceptible
to damage from heat stress you see that
right after flowering began there was a
period of few days with low nighttime
temperatures but that probably didn't
help uh this planting out so much
especially once we actually looked at
the data it was clear that they had been
exposed to a lot of heat stress
and then um you'll see that later on
closer to harvest there were some very
high nighttime temperatures but those
were also probably not so impactful
in terms of yield and quality
what was really impacting this planting
was that period right before flowering
began
so the
damage that is caused by heat stress
is
damage to flower structures
and
high night temperatures
cause the anthers to
not open up and release their pollen so
uh in the picture
up here
where you see those anthers with all the
little round
things inside those are the pollen
grains and those are supposed to not be
in the anthers anymore they're supposed
to have been released onto the stigma
which is that sort of shiny part of the
flower
that you see there
and they should be sticking on there
germinating growing a pollen tube down
and fertilizing the egg cell to make a
seed however they can't do that when the
pollen grains stay inside the anthers
on the right side of this slide you can
see
an image of some anthers that have
opened up and released their pollen
these are anthers from a plant that was
not heat stressed and so there's not
very many pollen grains left in the
anthers instead they have all ended up
on the style and stigma of the flower
where they can do their job of
pollinating
the other thing that happens with high
night temperatures in addition to the
pollen not ending up on the style and
stigma sometimes the pollen that does
end up there is lower quality so it is
less likely to germinate and form a
pollen tube and cause fertilization so
again the result is
that you have fewer seeds
you have
misshapen pods because of those fewer
seeds you might not have pods setting or
at all
some pods that set might or board or
fall off
and if you aren't setting pods at all
you may have delayed harvest if you have
some pods set and then
um a period of high temperatures you may
have a split set which really makes
people crazy when it comes to harvest
time
so i'm going to show you a couple of
different varieties and sort of the way
that they have responded to heat stress
differently but all
susceptible so
for this particular
variety it has set a few pods early but
you can see that they are all short they
have only one or two seeds set in them
maybe three but that's not sufficient to
form a good sized pod and
then these plants after a period of time
have not
set any additional pods they're still
flowering because they have not been
able to
to set pods because of heat stress
here's another variety some varieties
will set pods even though the embryos
there are no embryos because the eggs
have not been fertilized and those pods
often look like these little
hook shaped pin pods there are no seeds
forming inside of there and those pods
will fall off most likely
certainly not make a marketable snapping
and uh then there are some varieties
this is caprice which is uh one of the
standard varieties grown in delaware
this variety tends to set a fair number
of pods under heat stress but many of
them are misshapen
and are probably going to be graded as
coals
so these pictures are illustrating the
importance of
quality grading when evaluating
varieties for heat tolerance
so at the top are two varieties that
have been very heat tolerant in many of
our trials
pv-857 and bridger
and at the bottom are two varieties that
have uh
that are quite heat susceptible caprice
and affirmed
so
uh
for each of the varieties it's a 300
gram sample of pods that has been graded
into
the fancy
number one and call categories
and um you'll see that for pv857
and bridger most of the pods are ending
up in the fancy and number one
categories and not so many pods in the
coal categories whereas for caprice and
affirmed most of the pods are in the
call category
so
as i have been evaluating varieties for
heat tolerance
this grading process has been a part an
important part of evaluating
them not just looking at total yield
you can
certainly some varieties just don't
produce very many pods at all but others
produce a lot of pods but they're calls
okay
so i'm gonna show you two charts um from
one from the 2020 trials and one from
the 2020 one trials in both years had
two plantings of
many round potted snap bean varieties
in 2020
the early trial was planted june 9th
that was the trial for which i showed
you some weather data earlier that it
was harvested uh starting july 27th
through august 3rd and this trial was
exposed to a lot of heat stress
in the early part of july during
flowering
then
that same year we had a late trial that
was planted july 15th so this is more
towards the end of our um
production period and this was meant to
be a low stress trial and indeed it was
a low stress trial so in this chart
the orange and gray bars are the early
trial that was heat stressed and the
blue and gray bars are the later trial
which was
not heat stress you can see that overall
yields were much higher
in
the
later trial that was not stressed
[Music]
but
some of the varieties did produce higher
yields
or decent yields i should say in the
trial that was heat stress
the
colored parts of the bars are the
marketable yield and the gray parts are
the coal yield
um
the highest
yielding varieties in the heat stress
trial were pv857 and bridger
um pv857 and bridger are two varieties i
mentioned already
they are
pv857 is a variety that has been in our
trials um
for many years
um and has looked good in the heat
stress trials and bridger is a variety
that is in the 2020 and the 2021
trials and looked good as far as
its heat stress tolerance in both of our
heat stress trials in those years
you can see that there are many other
varieties in
these trials and in the late trial um
there were quite a few varieties that
outperformed pv-857
and bridger the very heat-tolerant
varieties so
um
they uh were
they were definitely not the highest
yielding varieties when they weren't
stressed but under heat stress
they
were
had significantly higher marketable
yields than all of the other varieties
and
this is a similar chart for our 2021
trials
so again in this case
the early planted trial um which was
planted june 9th or sorry june 2nd
um and harvested at the end of july was
exposed to heat stress
the later later planet trial which was
actually also supposed to be a heat
stress trial was planted june 16th it
did not end up being impacted by heat
stress instead it was severely impacted
by
pythium
uh
root rot the plants came up we had a
very good stands and then we had a
really sizable rain event that
made the field very wet for quite a
while and um we had a lot of plants
die um
at sort of the first trifoliate leaf
stage
uh in this trial and what we isolated
from the roots or at least what the
plant pathologists isolated from the
roots was pythium so we think that's
what did this end later on we're
harvesting we saw some um
pod rot from pythium as well
in this field
so uh varieties that had decent yields
in
the second trial
the blue and gray bars those are
varieties that had some root disease
tolerance
so in the
heat stress trial
the
highest yielding varieties were bridger
pv-857 and jaguar jaguar was a variety
that was new to the trials this year
those three varieties had significantly
higher marketable yield than all of the
other varieties in the trial
in the
in the heat stress trial
and um
i also wanted to highlight
hmx
0175
which
is apparently been named bird
and will be available at some point in
the future
the
not too distant future i'm told um so
that variety was also in the 2020
trials it
seems to be okay in terms of heat
tolerance but it was the highest
yielding variety
in uh the second trial that was exposed
to a lot of root disease that variety
seems to have an awful lot of disease
tolerance or at least epithelium
which is what we had
in this situation
so i'm just going to review some of the
heat tolerant varieties um
[Music]
and mention uh the flat potted uh trials
we've done too so pv857
is a variety that has certainly shown a
lot of heat tolerance in the trials
we've conducted in the past it's a three
to four
sieve size variety bridger is slightly
larger size b and four to five cis size
and it was trialled in 2020 and 2021
and has similar level of heat tolerance
to pb 857
jaguar was only trialled in 2021 but in
that heat stress trial it performed very
well um
and had significantly higher yield um
than other varieties in the trial along
with pbh57 and bridger
and
bird i mentioned is a variety that seems
to have
okay heat tolerance but also a fair
amount of root disease
resistance
i've also trialled flat potted snap
beans in
2019 and 2021
um simbara
is the variety that seems to have the
most heat tolerance among
the flat potted varieties that i have
looked at
and uh
i just wanted to acknowledge that i've
had a lot of help from uh some young
people over the years of this these
trials uh from 2017 to 2021 to get these
beans picked and graded and these are
photos of some of them the
variety trial reports from each year
are available on our website if you
google search delaware vegetable variety
trials you'll find our variety trials
page and the snappy and variety trial
results are on that page
the 2021 trial report is completed but
it hasn't been posted yet so hopefully
it will be up there soon
all right and that is the end of my
presentation i guess i can take any
questions
thank you so much emily i'm going to
start off with a question um
since it's the night time temperatures
that are the problem
have there been any growers down there
that have tried irrigating at night and
i know that's probably one of the worst
things you can do from a disease
standpoint but has anybody tried to do
that to reduce the temperature
so um we tried an experiment uh in
2020 where we were trying that with lima
beans
and um
we were not
really able to
decrease the temperature in the field
sufficiently to have the effect that we
were hoping
we are also obviously really concerned
about potential disease problems
that is something that we continue to
think about
as far as whether we could use the
center pivot irrigation systems
to cool fields at night but we
um
yeah and i don't know of any growers
that have tried it
okay thank you other questions for emily
emily do you know how much this carries
over to other types of beans if this is
just a snap bean thing or if you're also
in packing limas and flat pods and dry
beans
okay so um since
snap beans and like dry phaseolous
vulgaris dry beans um
are the same species the impact is the
same
so is this
and um lima beans are different species
but still phaseolous
and it is
basically the same effects
that i would say that temperature
thresholds are maybe a little higher for
lima beans
generally say about 70 degrees is when
we start seeing
problems
in lima beans especially baby limas the
larger seeded
lima beans so fort hook types or the
larger seeded pole types are more heat
sensitive than baby limas
sure okay thank you so much um
you know when i when i see the pictures
and
your summary it makes us all think about
what we're seeing in the fields here as
well and the 60
that threshold is is
is rather scary because we have many
nights even here in upstate new york
that we don't get below that so so i'll
be your speaker for the next 25 minutes
and i also introduce uh masi who's a
research associate in my laboratory
she's been with me for the past eight
years has really helped a lot as we've
put this presentation together uh we're
somewhat reviewing the first 20 years of
my career at cornell starting the 80s
and 90s and you'll see references going
into the early 2000s
some of the people that we've worked
with including steve
along the way with with looking at snap
beans as it's such an important
crop for us here in new york state
i want to thank julie and steve for for
putting this together and reaching out
to invite
me along with some of the other speakers
and i really really enjoyed the first
speaker and
some of the things going on there with
it with the heat stress so so really
really good presentation there kudos
so what i want to do is really kind of
talk about several factors start off
with seed factors and affect germination
and stand establishment then go into the
field factors and then try to tie the
seed and the field factors as the
effects stain establishment but actually
take this all the way to what is the
yield potential as well
so we kind of start off with this uh
kind of encyclopedia
definitions of bean seeds going to the
seedling
rather than just looking at the bean as
just a living entity our goal is for
every cell and seeds to germinate emerge
uniformly in the field and then take all
the way out to its maximum yield
potential
so
how is this going to happen the first
thing you need to do is start off with
high quality seeds
looking at the figure on the right is
going to be generalized
depiction of what's going on after seeds
are produced on the mother plant till
the time that they're planted there's
that storage period that time between
seed harvest and then sowing and then
what events are occurring on
at the whole plant level we're looking
at a decline in germination with the
blue line where the seeds can maintain
the germination and then kind of drop
off but we're seeing
earlier events going on with the decline
in the seed vigor
and so that's really important
especially as we talk about stress and
the effect of stress on germination
so along with
seed aging that can occur an effective
decline
we know that moisture content is very
important
particular to the snap beans this is
also true of dry beans and if you're
working with and if you
plant soybeans this is also important
for soybeans
but this is our moisture meter
in our laboratory it's a non-destructive
technique also the new york state seed
testing laboratory now based in albany
also does this on a routine basis
let's focus on the graph and we've got
lots of graphs and tables i try to walk
everybody through so you can kind of see
what the main the main talking points
are that i'm trying to make
so
this relationship here we call a
moisture isotherm basically if you store
seeds and we're seeing over this wide
range of relative humidities the seeds
can either take up or lose moisture and
they're going to have a corresponding
seed moisture content
this is basically the moisture kind of
the seeds as you would open up the bag
so on the upper part you can see the
storage losses increase in other words
the seeds age faster in storage and
again that's true of all seeds as they
will age faster as we increase
temperature but also as we increase
moisture content
bean seeds are also very susceptible to
mechanical damage handling damage this
is a physical damage and also hydration
injury which we call chilling injury or
inhibition chilling injury so i have two
contrasting so the seed companies are
aware of this the processing the large
companies and they try to you know we
try to find the kind of the sweet spot
of having the seed moisture content
kind of as an intermediate between these
but let's look further as we look at
some of the data from these type of work
uh
some things that we've done just a lot
of times we're in the laboratory we want
to do a rapid aging test so here we're
looking at in the left-hand side just a
six-week period by putting seeds at warm
degrees 40 degrees centigrade is over
100 degrees fahrenheit with high
moisture content so that aging occurs
very rapidly
but you say well that that's not really
realistic for way we're storing seeds
but if you're storing seeds even at
lower temperatures and lower moisture
contents if you have carryover seeds for
a year's time
these same relationships are going to
occur as the decline in germination
the square boxes are we call abnormal
seedlings so the seeds sprout but they
don't grow normally and then eventually
everything is dead
so that is kind of the type
that chorus here just abbreviated in
time but the same would play out under
less stressful situations in the storage
environment
let's look at the figure on the right
hand side
is here we're looking at
the early phases the decline in vigor so
one of the very first symptoms of the
vigor loss the seeds start to germinate
slower
you can see
the time course here this is not with
beans this is with another vegetable
crop but the seeds are starting to
germinate slower and if we went further
in aging then there'd also be a decline
in the percentage of seeds that do
germinate
again we're on the theme of moisture
content and the importance of moisture
content
mike dixon was a plant breeder this is
before griff
mike had tremendous insights
understanding the role and the impact
that plant breeding could have on the
bean as far as their germination and
stain establishment occurs and
especially with regards to stress
one thing's as i mentioned is being
signs are very susceptible to the
mechanical damage so being uh so mike
set up this uh stress test which is
basically a as you can see a
stove pipe onto sanding seeds onto a
steel plate it's a very good screening
technique he used he also did work with
with heat tolerance too so again a lot
of that stuff tends to be forgotten but
a lot of classic work was done here at
geneva on breeding for stress tolerance
i want to show you the figure on the
right is after those seeds get
damaged
after they get dropped we're looking at
an x-ray and i was on sabbatic in oregon
state
this goes back to 1990 when i did some
of this work they had a nice x-ray
facility there for doing seed quality
work and you can see those hairline
cracks
in the seeds the same thing is to say if
you you you
fell and you broke your arm or your
wrist and you can see hairline fractured
with an x-ray we can pick those up those
damages to the cod leads again are going
to express themselves during the
germination and tremendously weaken the
seedling
also along with the lines with the
moisture content this particular low
moisture content is their sensitivity to
cold temperatures chilling temperatures
we had developed a cold stress test you
can see the beans on the left
and here we're looking at the same
variety the same line and all we've done
is changed the initial moisture content
of that seed
so the table in the purple on the right
hand side again same variety same
seedling the only thing that was
different is we changed the initial seed
moisture content to low moisture eight
percent or a high moisture 12
the warm germination which is your
standard germination test doesn't really
show too much so an ideal condition not
too much difference but now when we put
them in that shilling stress now we see
a very large difference where those low
moisture content are really getting
injured
also
the seeds that were mechanically dropped
to induce the physical damage
again and we're seeing them the low
moisture content seeds and then finally
to field emergence and field emergence
also under a cold wet planting situation
in the spring also shows the effect of
that
moisture content and particularly the
low moisture content of having a very
negative effect
on the stand establishment potential
so those are the seed related factors
now we're going to move into the soil
environment
those field factors
so at the experiment station at the
vegetable we used to call the old
vegetable crops research farm
uh i was able to obtain data the soil
temperatures are recorded on a daily
basis the minimum and maximum this is
under bare soil at the two inch planting
down
so we're looking at an average over a
nine year period
in blue is the maximum soil temperature
again recorded in in that day time the
minimum it'd be the coldest temperature
so you see quite a diurnal in other
words a daily fluctuation in soil
temperatures at that two inch depth
why is this important this is important
to snap beans it's important to vessels
it's important to our friends working at
fruits to all crops because this is
basically is this the soil environment
that the plants are going to be exposed
to
why it's important to us and snack beans
is that we try to plant early and try to
get earlier in the season especially as
those low soil temperatures what is
going to be the effect on the
germination what stress is going to be
imposed on the time for the seeds to
germinate
so here where we have data that we've
taken out of the literature
so there's different factors that affect
the time for a bean seed or really any
vegetable crop seed to germinate one is
called the base temperature
so in case a base temperature means if
you go below that temperature
the seeds are not progressing uh to them
being able to germinate so that's kind
of the lower limit
then the other is the growing degree
days which is like a heat sum unit
that's used so we can calculate this
showing data from two different sources
and some of the data where it overlaps
you see quite good agreement
as you'd expect
under warmer soil temperatures
seeds germinate very rapidly kind of
really just jump out of the ground there
and the warm soil temperature is above
say 75 degrees but it is that soil
temperature and this is now an average
soil temperature this is not showing
that that day night fluctuation but a
constant temperature but as we cool the
soil as it gets lower and lower now look
at we're out to 14 days past 21 days if
you're at a temperature station
temperature down to 55 degrees
so so essentially that jump you're
trying to get if you're trying to plant
early can definitely be offset by that
extra period of time it's going to take
for emergence to occur
another stress is water stress and
everybody that grows crops is well
familiar with water stress and really
can be in two forms one is water stress
in the form of a drought stress now i
didn't have data
for you on bean seeds this happens to be
on him but it really doesn't matter
because it shows the generalized
response of seed germination as we
decrease the water availability
we don't have to get fancy with the
units these mpa the megapascals but just
knowing that we're going to zero means
pure water and then we're getting less
water available
let's look at the very profound effect
that has on the germination time course
so the seeds would germinate very
rapidly if water is available but then
as less and less water available we're
starting to see a slowdown in the
germination and then eventually a
reduction in those seeds that can
germinate
so essentially this is again a major
environmental stress as the water stress
as a drought would occur
now if we went further if we kept on
getting even drier the seeds are not
going to sprout at all in the ground
they'll just sit there they're going to
sit there and wait for a rain or
irrigation or some supplemental change
in the soil moisture content for them to
germinate so the seeds have not perished
the other extreme
of anything
too much of a good thing is a very wet
soil condition and we can see some of
the equipment that we had here lab
instrumentation to measure the oxygen
availability the soil oxygen diffusion
rate
that we can do in the laboratory so we
can kind of quantify things
so too much water is excluding that
oxygen from moving through the soil
seeds when they germinate are respiring
they're just like you and i we need to
breathe the seeds also need to respire
and once you see that graph on the right
it's a little bit tricky but look at the
bottom axis the soil oxygen fusion rate
and then the red line is the percent
seedling emergence
at high oxygen diffusion good soil
oxygen movement we see a very high
percentage termination but then we get
to a critical point where there's really
a crash and the seeds are able to
germinate
so once we get down below around about
80
on that scale then we see a very large
drop in the germination
unlike the drought stress where the
seeds are going to sit there these seeds
are going to die they're going to sit
there and rot
and because there's too much oxygen
available so this is kind of a of a
point of no return if you run into this
particular
scenario
the last of the physical stresses is a
soil crust
again from our research farm at geneva
you have a certain amount of of a clay a
heavier soil
generally our soils have low organic
matter so this is just showing the
nature of that physical crust
how do these soil crust form you have a
time
from the time of planting the seeds till
the time the emergence that's a critical
period
that's why the temperature is important
you want that time period from the time
of sowing from planting to emergence to
be short so the seeds can get up out of
the ground and going
what we're seeing here is a sequence of
event with rain raindrop
intensity the duration of the raindrop
is breaking down the soil structure
breaking down the soil aggregates so
this fine particles are starting to move
to the top and then the drying with sun
and wind we're getting a drying and so
basically that's where you get that
physical barrier so the seeds have
germinated they've sprouted but they're
not able to physically emerge and
obviously this have a dramatic effect on
delaying and reducing the percent stand
establishment
okay we're going to change now
into looking at what what is the effect
now we have a given seedline the
seedline is going to have both high
quality seeds but there's always you
know the germination is not going to be
a hundred percent on that seedling
there's going to be some low vigor seeds
also present in that seedline
so what is the consequence there when
we're looking at the seedling emergence
the rate of the seedling emergence out
in the field situation
so we asked this question again we're
going back into the 90s look at the
people there on the right hugh price bob
becker jim balerstein this is before
stephen even arrived on the scene david
was my research technician at the time
so we asked these really kind of
fundamental questions about how
important is these seeds to germinate
and emerge uniformly
so what we did is we took the seedlings
planted just the bag of seeds particular
seedline
try to get a target
distance between them about two inches
apart between the seedlings
then as the seedlings were coming up we
tagged the seedlings put a little little
colored tag on them if they were the
fastest to germinate we designated those
as they're early to emerge
there's the medium you can see just
emerge just getting to the first true
leaf stage and then there's the late
which i've come up you see the padlet
and still quite well behind the other
ones so now we take these three groups
tagged early
medium and late grow them all the way to
the harvest maturity harvest those by
group early medium and late
and then take that all the way for the
yield data
so let's look at the data we had two
years that we did this
1993 was a very cold and wet soil
situation i know these varieties have
all come and gone bush blue lake 47
most of you don't even remember what
that variety was
but i don't think it's really that
important again i don't know if our
newer varieties were planted today but i
suspect the response that we're looking
at here would translate over to the
varieties today again i'm speculating
here at this point but let's look at the
data way back from 93 when we did this
study
tagged the early
the medium and the late okay
and then we said well boy let's just
repeat this study we did this in 1994.
1994 was a very warm spring very warm
soil temperatures ideal conditions so
you can see they literally jumped out of
the ground
and coming up much sooner so under that
1993
and that cold we're seeing an emergence
of spread of over seven days
where in the 94 just a few days that is
going on there okay
now let's look at the yield data
starting off with a 93 cold wet stress
again taking as an emergence group
those that were early the medium and
late
projecting now in yield is ton per acres
we can see that the yield is largely
being carried by those that are early to
emerge
a drop off with the medium and then the
late are much lower much less yield
potential
so what is going on here is those late
to emerge are somewhat functional weeds
they're really competing with those fast
to emerge and really taking away you
know we're going to be hearing from lynn
about weeds but we also have the crop
itself can act somewhat as a weed as
it's competing against the main crop for
the carrying the yield potential
we also did sizing of the pods the twos
threes and fours the smaller size and as
you would expect the earlier to mature
also had earlier harvest so we see a
change there to a higher percentage of
the larger synth size the fives and
sixes
okay let's look at the 94 this let's
look at the also the bush blue like 47.
so now we're not seeing the distinction
between the early and medium as far as
statistics is concerned with you
remember they only come up about a day
or so apart from each other however the
late is significantly less and probably
what's going on here just like in any
sea life there's going to be low vigor
seeds present in that seed lot and those
low vigor seeds are also going to have
less yield potential and again they're
also competing against the early so it's
kind of a double whammy poor quality
seeds low vigor seeds within the seed
lab and also the competition against
those that are fast to emerge
i just want to summarize two other
studies here and then i'll show you a
bunch of tables and figures but just
kind of give you the highlights
again this is when when steve was on
board with us at this point working with
us and also with with ellen scherker who
was in the seed testing laboratory
so our first study was is
many of the growers
were purchasing seeds they had a
situation with carryover seeds in other
words you purchased the seeds for this
year you don't plant them this year you
carry over the seeds in the bag in the
barn until the next year so we simulated
that carryover seat with a very mild
kind of a seed aging technique to
simulate what happened over one year's
time to do that in a month or two
those carryover seeds had lower percent
lab germination we would expect that
than the non-aged seedling
however that loss in lab germination was
also directly related to the reduction
in field emergence but also decreased
yield so now we're seeing the linkage
that starting off with that high quality
seed is very important and it carries
soon not just to the state establishment
but also to the yield potential
stephen i came back with a study again
varieties come and go
but i think we can still learn some
things here we have four seed lots of
high style
one very high quality seed level 94 germ
three medium what i'm calling from 78 to
80 term all these would meet as federal
standards uh for germination of snap
beans
now the high quality seed lot had
greater field emergence than the other
three seedlings again we'd kind of
expect that but the yield from that high
quality than 94 germination was greater
in a range from about 12 to 18
than the other three seedlings so again
starting off with a high quality seed so
i just want to kind of i know i've hit a
lot of things and i do have a summary
that i've i've turned in so you have a
written copy of
follow this there's seed factors percent
termination start with high quality
seeds if you learn nothing else from
this presentation start with high
quality get good quality seeds to begin
with moisture content in particular in
beans really important increasing
moisture content the seeds will decline
faster in storage but decreased
moisture content
starts to increase their susceptibility
to the handling problems the hydration
the chilling injury problems field
factors are obvious with soil
temperature stress occurs
as we
lower that soil temperature and soil
water content of course the water is
necessary for germination but stress
occurs with either too much or too
little we saw the consequences of soil
crusting
but that uniform acetyl emergence is
linked to yield and so again getting
back to the theme the high quality seeds
have the potential for the greater
stands but also greater yield potential
so i want to thank everybody for your
attention i think we have a minute or
two for for questions
thank you alan it was fun to go back and
uh relive some of those things and and
with some of the issues that we still
have so i'm going to open it up to see
if there's any questions here for
for people
i think i again i know it's a lot in a
short period of time and again you're
seeing 20 years of my professional life
flash before your eyes in 25 minutes but
i think if you go back once the summary
becomes available to you you have the
same information that you can read
through and kind of help digest it a
little bit better
thank you yeah we will get that summary
out i guess one question for you alan is
and it goes right along with what we're
seeing here in your data
is you know sometimes we'll visit a
field growers field and depending on the
seed or the planter that they're using
uh their depth may be a little bit off
and there can be some variability there
and that gets right back into what you
were showing that then you might have
emergence
differences and and
so just the putting of the seed in the
field can have a huge difference too
right
that's a really good point stephen and
that's one that we we
you know we try to look at things kind
of carefully at the time but that's one
we we did not look at but something we
we could kind of still do especially
with some of the varieties we're growing
today but i think kind of the underlying
story from everything we've done is
anything that's going to
uh upset or
get a broader distribution the lack of
uniformity of emergence we're going to
see that changing so the depth of
planting uh is going to increase that
spread of the emergence time the time
for the ceilings come out of the ground
we're going to also see those same type
of trends as what i would predict great
so first of all um i would like to thank
uh liz maloney my technician um who
is really responsible for getting all of
our trials in the ground and i also want
to thank uh and acknowledge terry
bassisson at rutgers dwight liggin
felter at penn state and mark van gessel
because uh the projects that i'm going
to talk about in today's talk we all did
um together it with some collaborative
research
so i want to talk about
herbicides and the timing that
herbicides uh come into contact with the
crop and their impacts on snap bean
injury
and yield so herbicides are obviously
really uh important
for crop production in the united states
they're the most commonly applied
pesticides with respect to treated acres
across all of our cropping systems both
agronomic and specialty
now they're effective for managing
unwanted vegetation which helps us uh
preserve our yields but they can also
cause unintended injury some of that is
due to off target movement and some of
that is due to
applications that occur in the crop from
registered
herbicide materials
so first for off target movement
when we think off target movement the
first thing that comes up is spray drift
or maybe volatility spray drift being
the movement of spray droplets during
the application process
whereas volatility is the change in
state of a herbicide where it it goes
from a liquid to a gas it vaporizes off
of that surface and then causes damage
so we're going to really probably
primarily focus on spray drift and let's
face it the the gorilla in the room when
we're talking about spray drift over the
past couple of years
has been dicamba
and dicamba tolerant crops were
developed and commercialized because of
herbicide resistance
particularly the development of
glyphosate resistant weeds which evolved
in response to the development of
glyphosate resistant crops
but we know that auxins like dicamba can
move off target and they can cause
injury to sensitive crops and those can
be non-engineered soybeans and cotton or
they can be specialty crops like snap
beans
and snap beans are particularly
sensitive to dicamba
now dicamba use in soybeans is less
prevalent in new york but that doesn't
mean it's
non-existent uh these are pictures from
a field from western new york in 2022
again dicamba drift may not be a common
occurrence in new york but it can and
does happen
this
this field happened to be actually a
self-conflicted um scenario where a
grower went around the the edge of his
field
because he had horse weed slash mare's
tail and treat it with dicamba and that
dicamba moved off into
about five acres of the snapping crop
causing damage
so with uh the you know the rise in uh
dicamba use throughout the united states
and with the increase in reported
dicamba injury terry basilson at rutgers
and i uh started a trial in 2020
to look at the impacts of low doses of
dicamba on snapping injury and yield
when they were applied at either the v2
the first trifoliate leaf stage or at
first flower
and when we talked about low doses we
went down and looked at doses as low as
1 10 000 the field rate the field rate
being 22 ounces per acre
so this is our plant size at harvest as
a percent of the check so assume the
check is a hundred and everything is
adjusted
relative to that check if the check's
100 everything is adjusted down
and what we saw is that for
dicamba treatments at the one five
thousandth rate
or higher
we saw
plant stunting we saw growth inhibition
at that v2 stage
that that lasted throughout the season
and was visible at harvest timing
so we had injury and it manifest as as
distortions to leaves and stems but it
also manifests as growth inhibition and
we could see this
now we didn't see it with applications
made at first flower stage uh in fact we
didn't see any appreciable differences
in plant size at all so if you were
looking at these plants from a distance
you know there would be nothing
with respect to canopy development you
know that would would tip you off that
there was some sort of damage occurring
however what we did see is yield loss
nonetheless and so we saw yield loss
associated with z2 application but also
the first flower application so
the v2 application was in associated
with again the injury and the reductions
in plant size that we saw we saw the
reductions in the yield but we saw those
reductions in the first flower even
though we didn't see
smaller plants and that's because what
we had here
was these applications we had some
distortions but what it really did is it
interfered with the development of
flowers and pods and reduced our yields
so this this movement of uh off you know
chemicals that
are maybe applied in in adjacent fields
can have a significant impact on
snapping growth and development and this
can have a significant impact on the
amount of yield that you can
uh achieve
again at our highest rates you know
we're looking at a 97 percent yield loss
85 percent yola so these are substantial
now there's in crop applications so
applications that are made with
herbicides that are registered for use
in snap beans that can cause injury to
snap beans themselves and we're going to
talk about post-emergence herbicides and
we're going to talk about three of them
basagram reflex and raptor
they're important herbicides they're
often used in combination with each
other in part to manage
weeds because they do have different
spectrums of control
but also
in the case of raptor
wanting to tank mix it with basagram to
reduce injury potential now i do want to
point out there's two asterisks on this
on this slide and uh we'll talk about
this at um a later a later presentation
or timing is that we do have resistance
to
uh these um active ingredients to these
herbicides so with raptor we do know
that we have pigweeds in the state of
new york that are resistant to als
inhibiting herbicides
and with respect to the basagram we're
doing confirmatory studies right now
with kyle brunharo at penn state is that
we do have appear to have certain
populations in new york that are not
responding to bastogram we have one
population that we have survivors at
even um 12 pints per acre
rate
so again
injury can sometimes come from
applications made with registered
herbicides within the field again raptor
and raptor plus fastagran is is a really
good example of this we tank mix raptor
ambassador to reduce injury potential
you can see the yellowing uh from the
raptor applied by itself this is a slide
from mark van gessel and you can see um
less injury on the raptor plus bassogran
now we do know
that uh when it comes to using our
post-emergence herbicides uh there are
timing restrictions or timing
recommendations on the label about when
they can be used you know some say the
first trifoliate leaf stage some say the
second trifoliate leaf stage so we know
that we have to allow for plant growth
and development to increase the safety
potential of these products
we also know that if we don't have good
pre-emergence herbicide activity at the
start of the process you know at the
start of when we plant
say we don't get a pre-emergent
herbicide activated our weeds get up and
there's there's kind of this this uh
push-pull tug you know kind of going on
here that as our crop is getting older
and more developed uh so we can achieve
crop safety our weeds might be growing
as well and our application timings
being delayed means the weeds are taller
and they're going to be less effective
the herbicides are going to be less
effective for controlling them
so uh again there's a risk of spraying
early you know maybe wanting to go in as
early as possible to control uh the
weeds but there's also that potential
for adapt to the crop
last year we got um some uh questions
some about splitting the difference what
if like with ellen said you have you
know these timings where um
you know you don't get the the weed
emergence you know or you don't get uh
an equally merged stand and now you have
a stand that's at different growth
stages uh but you need to go in for
post-emergency management or what if you
don't get your pre-emergence herbicide
you know what kind of injury are we
going to see if we go too early you know
if it you know to make
uh to get the effective weed control
what kind of crop damage could we
possibly see
on those plants that aren't as well
established
uh so marvin gessel dwight liggin felter
and i put in a trial in 2021 to
specifically look at the timing
of
herbicide applications uh basagram
reflex ambassador with reflex or raptor
and to look at what happens if we apply
them at the cotyledon the unifolia or
the
first tribe foley at least stage
uh and this is uh the snapping injury
that we saw at two weeks after treatment
the herbicides are averaged over all of
the timings the application timings are
averaged over all the herbicides
what we saw and what we're showing is we
saw the majority of the injury with our
basagram and reflex applications
and we expected with the application
timing that we would see the most with
the cotyledon you know the next with the
the unifolia stage and the least with
the trifoliate what we saw in our
situation our collective data was our
tri our unifolia stage had the most
injury
there's a reason why for this and this
is going to get
into why we just can't think about the
herbicides and the crops alone
this is the data this is a comparison of
the data that mark captured at the
unifoliate stage two weeks after
treatment in delaware and the data that
i captured in new york and you can see
there's a real difference in the
unifoliate
um timing and the amount of injury that
we saw where we saw up to 70 75 percent
injury in our basagram plus reflex 40 to
60 injury with reflex ambassador plus
raptor and between 30 and 40 percent
with passagran alone whereas mark barely
got out of the 20s
there's a good reason for this if you
remember last july
uh we had a lot of rainfall and we
planted our snapping trial in late june
and we had significant amounts of
rainfall
uh and what happened is is our plants
got injured by the herbicide but they
also got injured by the amount of water
that we had
in our field and they were injured and
they just never caught back up this was
compounding stresses and they just never
grew out of it and ultimately this
injury that we observed resulted in
about a 25
yield loss uh in the number of
marketable snap beans
for our site across all of our
herbicides
so
herbicides are important for managing
weeds in the field and
specialty crops but they also cause
injury which can reduce yields
sometimes that herbicide injury comes
from applications that are made outside
of the field maybe on adjacent fields
last year i got calls about mesotrion
glyphosate and dicamba
drift on snap beans
and dose
the amount of herbicide that that uh the
crop comes into contact with and the
timing
of the contact is really going to
influence injury and yield
some injury can come from the labeled
herbicides applied in the crops
themselves and this can significantly be
influenced by timing the crop
development stage but the weather and
the environment at the time or near
application again compounding stresses
you can have one stress and then another
stress
that adds to it
just so you know for our 2022 research
plans we're going to be screening for
bentazon resistance uh in our lamb's
quarters we're going to be partnering
with wreckers in delaware for carryover
and additional drift trials we're
evaluating a new novel herbicide
valuation that we're hoping uh for
control of pigweeds and lamb's quarters
and we're going to be doing some
competition trials and um kind of
melding our timing studies to look at
the timing of
volunteer peak control in snap beans and
thank you very much to the people and
organizations who sponsored the research
very good thanks a lot so now thanks for
the opportunity to talk here um so this
is sort of a familiar topic that that's
a tricky one to deal with uh
lynn showed the the orca
traveling down the street in new york uh
great conditions for getting good bean
root rot
so we're going to have root rot there's
there's no getting around it but how do
you make it less bad
and so
for those of you a few of you unfamiliar
with being root rot um
there's a whole bunch of different
organisms that cause bean root rot
fusarium and pythium are probably the
most common ones um
the
presentation of the disease is a little
bit different with each one
but
my simple-minded approach to it is that
most of these are there all the time so
you have an oculus no matter what you do
you just want to keep the population of
the inoculum as low as possible
avoid infection conditions and keep the
beans happy so that they're growing well
that's really the best you can do
thankfully cover crops can be very
helpful for achieving those goals
so when we think about
growing our beans so on the left there
we see
um that we want to have a fairly
flat surface so that we can get those
beans ideally they would not actually be
touching the ground then you're going to
get pod rods but
there's really not a lot of space in
between there it's easy to get splashing
um
but we want to keep that surface flat so
that the
harvester can come through and pick
those beans up so that has implications
for how we manage the surface of the
soil
so one of the you know if you want good
infiltration
you don't want compaction
but we have some good devices for
creating compaction in bean fields
particularly during harvest
uh particularly if it's a little wet
during harvest there's you can't wait
another day or two for the field to dry
out or the
beans will be
so over mature they're not useful so
this is a
a challenging call to make
um you if you're going go into a wet
field to harvest you are
expecting to have more root rot in the
future there's just no getting around it
but we can counteract that a little bit
so one of the
important points to make about cover
crops is if you really want the cover
crop advantage you also have to reduce
tillage so i have a figure here this is
from tennessee where they were doing
um two different winter cover crop
treatments and compared to fallow
and
it shows what the infiltration rate is
so when you have a heavy rain how how
quickly does the or how much water can
you get rid of
uh in the first several hours
and
in the tilled ground the cover crops
really didn't have that much effect it
went from like an inch and a half of
infiltration to about two inches of
infiltration so it mattered but it
wasn't great
if they reduced the tillage
and that's all they did they got a
similar effect so from an inch and a
half to two and a half but they combine
that with the cover crops and now the
cover crop can do its work on improving
infiltration now they were getting five
inches of infiltration and since we have
rainfall events now of four inches or so
the difference between having two and a
half inches of infiltration capacity and
five is enormous
um
but how do you do that in a
in a bean rotation so on the left i've
just done a little schematic of
something a reduced tillage system
uh that
uh is actually it's working for some
bean farmers in new york the
um
having
uh the gps guided
steering so you can hit these slots it's
useful but the idea is to have the
lighter colored areas
is the tilled zone and the darker
colored areas are the until zone so this
is with the deep zone tillage
tool the darker area now has a place for
the roots to stay to decompose
for the worms to go for all those things
that generate infiltration they have a
place to continue doing that you're not
destroying all the infrastructure every
time you tilt
so anything you can do to reduce that
tillage
in a zone so it's not
gentler tillage you're not going from
moldboard chisel or anything like that
it's leaving some parts of it until it
is the key
in this one i've also drawn in a lighter
color on the surface that
for
growing beans you do have to incorporate
residue or cultivate or something so
having a little layer of soil on top
that does get cultivated is fine the key
is to leave those big blocks of until
soil
as best you can so it's it's something
that is happening in new york i don't
think the
adoption is huge but i think there's a
lot of value to going there
and this is showing what happens when
you get the soil aggregation we've got
the crumb allows you can see that
there's
opportunity for infiltration also for
absorption of water into those
aggregates so it's not free water that's
letting the pathogens grow
and this is what it looks like when you
have
no-till
um this is just a couple of years
of soil that was until that we're
basically doing what i diagrammed before
and
those of you familiar with the vegetable
research farm that we've got and
very high potential silt loam soil that
if you beat it to pieces it will form
concrete very nicely um and sometimes
when we do research we beat it to pieces
so this is what i started with and
what i ended up with and you can see
there's quite a few big holes there
those are actually where worms live
there's small holes where the roots have
been and there's some little roots
sticking out the bottom too
so you're getting
holes infiltration in a structure
that
will support heavier equipment as well
so you're
you have the potential to do less
compaction with this method also
and
forming the aggregates they're in
all different sizes so here shows the
different scales
of the aggregates so that
the macro aggregates are really the
roots and the high fee that are forming
those um the micro aggregates
you're down to your
fungi in large part are forming those
to show what that really looks like in
action so this is
in the middle you see a root
and around it you see soil particles of
various sizes and detritus of various
things
and this is what
a root looks the soil sheath looks like
it's glued together those are aggregates
that are formed this root was washed
with water before they took the
micrograph so this is what does not wash
off it's pretty good glue and as you can
see it's a nice aggregate all different
sizes of things in there and makes a
nice big particle that goes on to the
last for a long time
those make the tillage easier
and
makes the water run away or get absorbed
so that your root roth pathogens don't
have good a chance and your
beans are healthier
so i'm going to talk about some specific
cover crops now
that can be helpful so
um
i think quite a few people have tried
tillage radish
as a cover crop
and it behaves pretty nicely
but for getting at the
pathogens that cause root rot rapeseed
is actually better
it produces more of the suppressive
compounds in the roots
this is what it looks like after
we've had a freeze so it's starting to
die down
all this green stuff is protein that's
going to decompose during the course of
the winter
and into the springtime
the roots are really where the action is
the roots are already
right
up next to your pathogens
and so when the roots die and
the glucosinolates break down they kill
the pathogens and reduce those
populations
this is
uh
brown mustard so there's a couple
varieties pacific gold and caliente they
also stay relatively low you just have a
little bit of a stem on these so it dies
easily during the winter but they've
been bred for high glucosinolates so
they're more effective in some other
climates it
makes sense to do these as a as a plow
down but in our climate that really
doesn't end up making sense relying on
the roots makes more sense
and so this is what you want it to look
like in the beginning of march
so just about now when the snow melts on
the fields this is roughly what your
brown mustard should look like so they
have the dying roots have released the
toxic gas next to the pathogens so you
see you've reduced tillage
you've killed the pathogens you have
roots in there that are improving the
percolation so all of the things you're
looking for
are happening here and the only thing
that's happened is that you've planted
the mustard seed
it's a pretty good deal
so that uh
is sort of the num the number one cover
crop approach
um
and the mustards for western new york
it's really the the 10th to the 20th of
august is really the sweet spot for
planting these you get good growth you
get
no seed production
deep rooting
so that's the ideal
but you can go to the very beginning of
september you get
about a third of the biomass
compared to a mid august so it's you
take a big hit on the biomass but it's
still
worthwhile that late
the classic that people use winter rye
um definitely helpful for maintaining
infiltrate infiltration um having the
soil
dry out better
so this this is triticale i like
triticale because it actually has a
noticeably stronger root system than rye
and the roots are where the action is
right um so we like that
you can see on the very right how big
so that's a two and a half deep root
system on
rye that has not started to bolt very
much yet
but if you're growing beans of course
you want to terminate it early so the
rye in this picture is probably a little
bit on the big side
there are no stems you definitely want
to terminate it before the stems if
you're going to prepare
a seed bed that is suitable for beans
definitely a good practice here
sudan grass is also really good at
improving percolation
and at suppressing
root rot pathogens
however it leaves so much residue and
such a big crown that you can't
realistically plant and harvest beans uh
immediately after a sweden grass cover
crop
so it would have to be
uh in a year before or following
the snap beans
having it in the rotation somewhere is
definitely good
but i would not put that one
right before the beans or it will be a
huge headache in the springtime
so what don't you do legumes legumes are
great hosts for
bean
root rot pathogens and so
um
following uh clover or
rot would typically be about twice as
bad as if you didn't have them
in your beans so
legumes have an important place in the
overall rotation but not preceding beans
so you probably knew that one already
but i thought i'd throw it in there
so the key reducing root rot so the the
pathogens are always there
can't get around that you want to reduce
their population to the extent you can
you want to make sure that you have
as much infiltration in the soil uh as
possible and water holding in the soil
is possible and you want to keep your
beans as happy as possible and
yeah they don't like hypoxia i think
reason
alan taylor showed how unhappy they are
uh when they don't get oxygen uh and
yeah lynn showed but uh
that they don't grow out of the
herbicide effects either
so
percolation and water holding super
important when growing beans
so what are the practices
reducing traffic
controlling traffic i think the
the move to
gps controlled
tractors and controlled traffic
and
large scale
vegetable production is fantastic we're
in effect doing permanent beds there
it has huge benefits
about reducing the tillage volume rather
than the tillage intensity is probably
useful because those untilled areas are
the ones that develop
all of the holes all of the support
structures
for equipment
it's a big change to do that
but it seems to be paying off well in
new york
and then use the cover crop so the
the usual
winter grain over the winter but
terminated early we're using the
crucifer cover crops in the fall having
them winter kills so that it leaves the
soil surface in a good condition
for planting and harvesting beans
so that's where i'm going to finish up
mine
thank you thomas any questions for
thomas
and i see lynn and alan are still here
as well so if you have any questions for
them feel free
and i've got
i see there's people like
don sweet and roger ward on here who who
know this stuff what's going to make
this
these things uh
where where are these techniques likely
to be implementable for
snapping growers that you work with i'd
be keen to hear that
i think overall the use of cover crops
and and a lot of this
has improved but in processing
vegetables still some you've got the
you know we step in and break some of
the
tillage practices that they're using for
other crops when you get the peas and
snap beans a lot of the things you want
to do with zone tillage restrictment
you know word
kind of the odd link with whether it's
peas some i mean beans we're doing some
zone till or some strip tilling with
um
but most of us all of you need more of a
clean tillage type thing to reduce you
know contaminant side of things
right i like to see some more um
like those uh
mustard uh cover crops and some of that
um
some places though they just don't fit
in depend depending on what their
rotation is on some of these farms but
um in some of the places where they were
they could um that looks like a great
opportunity
and one of the nice things about
vegetable rotations is that
you're harvesting a lot of the season so
there's a lot more opportunities to put
in a cover crop than there is for the
field crops
and taking advantage of that
soon after harvest is possible
i think can really pay off
and the focus on the
on what the roots are doing it um
allows you to
think about the
the needed clean tillage which is so
important for snap beans and i think
a detraction for using
cover crops um
where the if you think the shoot the
shoot part of the cover crop has to be
handled a certain way
if you let the roots do the work
deal with the shoot independently in a
way that's best for the snap beans
i think that may provide a little bit of
an
extra latitude
where
sort of the normal practices don't don't
let you grow the snap beans afterwards
do you have any idea what the cost is
for some of those uh different uh cover
crops
yeah the crucifers are still running
three or four dollars a pound typically
um and um five to seven pounds an acre
is a good
target uh
amount
so it's
it's not too bad
everything else seems to have gone up
but those those remain a pretty good
bargain
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu